nick carter and wife lauren kitt have
welcomed their new bundle of joy
on thursday the singer tweeted out that
he and lauren have given birth to baby
number three
writing quote we are proud to announce
that our baby has officially arrived
but the former backstreet boy also
shared that the baby's birth didn't
exactly go according to plan
he says as a parent knows all too very
well sometimes things don't turn out the
way you plan it
we have been experiencing some minor
complications but things are looking a
little better after the first night
before the birth nick was keeping fans
updated through instagram on wednesday
posting this photo of himself from the
hospital quote
yes i'm a believer i asked god to give
us strength to protect mommy and baby
thankfully i made it through the fire
a source tells et that nick and his
family are still at the hospital
and while it's been a hard time for
everyone the baby is expected to be fine
and they look forward to going home
in january the couple announced that
they were expecting by posting this
video of their sonogram
writing sometimes life blesses you with
little surprises
it's an eye-opener nick and lauren are
already parents to a five-year-old son
odin and one-year-old daughter sirsha
and before kids came into the picture
nick gushed to e.t
about how he knew his wife lauren was
the one
she was a woman who wasn't afraid to
tell me
like no or say no i don't like that or
just a strong woman i i needed someone
to
to really be constructive with me
you know and and and find a way to
i mean she she grounds me she levels me
out
um the yin the yang that whole thing
um and i and i really i'm able i know
this is weird but i'm able to really
sort of she's like my shield you know i
mean and i'm her shield vice versa